[Musik]
jeder kennt diesen frosch und kann einen
papierflieger falten vielleicht habt ihr
euch auch schon mal an so was an getraut
der kranich hier ist wahrscheinlich das
bekannteste beispiel der uralten
japanischen origami kunst aber wie um
alles in der welt entsteht aus einem
einfachen blatt papier so was wahre
origami meister können mit
verschiedensten techniken ohne
hilfsmittel und werkzeuge unfassbare
kunstwerke schaffen marius und ich
hingegen haben höchstens mal aus
langeweile dieser werte im restaurant
gefeiert
das wollen wir heute ändern und um
herauszufinden wer von uns möglichst
schnell möglichst komplexe origami
figuren lernen kann hat unseren
außenstehender diese neuen modelle in
drei verschiedenen schwierigkeitsstufen
rausgesucht die wir in nur drei stunden
lernen müssen und zwar auswendig nach
ablauf der zeit müssen wir die gelernten
figuren ohne anleitung falten und
bekommen für jede richtige davon je nach
schwierigkeitsstufe einen zwei oder drei
punkte
und da ist trotz meiner niederlage in
der letzten folge auf marius kanal drei
zu zwei für mich steht könnte ich heute
schon die erste staffel tolle reverse
marius gewinnen es ist also matchball
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist das sind einmal die neuen figuren
die wir machen können das kann man noch
nicht aus papier das noch nicht verlernt
was das rechte und das sieht aus wie ein
schwan
das klingt das aufhängen drastisch also
zeit geht los in 321 das ins geld borgt
hinzu denn also ich meine dass irgendwas
kommt ein leichtes den lady baccumer das
ist sinnvoll krank sagt es so du hast
einfach so
also ich hab schon wieder krank und mona
diesem punkt kann man ja schon mal so
stehen also also ich glaube auch ein
essentieller fehler von mir war dass das
ding einfach nicht brot ist aber der ist
ja nicht so mit jod marius der
direktwahl das schwierigste an bringt
ich aber nicht mal hoch der stufe 2 mit
boarding kranich direkt das ist heftig
wo mein gott das schlau wer sich royale
ausgedacht hatten einschätzung nicht
wahr dass man hat das so und jetzt
schaltet man das
so auch und hat dann hier sind innenraum
kreiert irgendwie ist die alpha
plötzlich habe ich hier ein tier gebaut
also wir nicht pushen aber dass nur ein
das ist ja übel gaal mit zu gesicht und
an mal gucken wie weit ich das auswendig
hingebracht marius jetzt theoretisch
schon drei punkte und ich nur ein
pascal ist hab das vor das gefühl dass
es eigentlich recht logisch ist was da
passiert mich nicht auswendig schon ganz
gut aber nicht dass am ende wieder so
ist wie bei den clans ja alles vergessen
habe
[Musik]
fühlst du dich schon beruhigt nehmen
puls ist auf 180 fahrer entspannt ja es
auch im ruhrpott obwohl origami seinen
ursprung bei den zeremonien faltungen
von buddhistischen mönchen hat und auch
heute er wegen seiner meditativen
wirkung beliebt ist sind wir nicht die
einzigen die das ganz gerne mal mit
etwas nervenkitzel versehen so gab es in
der geschichte des origami auch unter
experten immer wieder wettbewerber zum
beispiel darüber wer einen käfer
realistischer falten kann und auch diese
kunstwerke sind alle nur aus einem
einzigen blatt entstanden bei unseren
modellen braucht man dann doch noch
etwas mehr fantasie handy weg machen wir
die erste dreier figur mal aus dem kopf
ach das ist der insight überholt kilda
um einen gott hört sich so nach einer so
könnten pro technikern der ich nach dem
ams und inside the world und dann jetzt
gegen sideways verschuldet
und dann kam nicht passt der kann nix co
so kann ich den ball eigentlich noch
kann ich kann zwei figuren jetzt kehrte
reversed fold ist da quasi von so
einfach wie so ein fehler einer matrix
ist sollte eigentlich gehen der hund den
ich und marios hier falten sieht zwar
simpel aus hat es aber in sich denn für
ihn müssen wir neben den komplizierten
inside reverse falls gleich mehrere
schwierige judgement vogels machen im
gegensatz zu den meisten anderen falten
bei denen man sich immer an einer ecke
oder kannte orientieren kann muss man
bei diesen judgement holz selbst
einschätzen wo genau sie verlaufen
sollen das ist für blutige anfänger die
uns besonders schwierig und
dementsprechend unterschiedlich fallen
auf unsere ergebnisse aus
[Musik]
also ich bin gespannt ich habe gar kein
planen die viele jetzt gelernt hat ich
habe gar keinen plan belgier vor allem
das ist ja welche und die haben auch
kein plan aber die richtig kann
sozusagen nur so ok keine zeit zu
verlieren ich schon mal an mit dem hund
ich bin so gespannt ich will wissen was
mal was gemacht hat das erst einmal
wieder die eule überdies c jetzt sind
drei stunden schon so einige figuren
drauf zu haben schon hätte ich nicht
gedacht
die sache ist also ich hoffe einfach ich
habe mehr punkte weil sonst direkt die
ganze staffel von die lehrer sollen
sparen und nicht der hund aber ok kommen
auch die zwischen auto die hundeschnauze
ist besonders schwierig es braucht hier
äußerste präzision und übung um aus der
dünnen papier spitze mit hilfe eines
inside reverse falls eine gute
hundeschnauze zu falten gelingt dieser
kniff nicht besteht das risiko für diese
figur keine punkte zu bekommen
das sieht aus wie ein schwarzer die
menschenfiguren nummer eins ist fertig
das war jetzt mein stay figur mal gucken
ob ich die anderen noch hinbekommen wenn
man jetzt hier immer falsch weitet ist
immer bei dem ding weil dort auf der
winkel nicht zu steil werden sondern es
hat ja so ein ganz komische körperform
ist der bruder harry wörz vor
bis auf dass der kopf ein bisschen zu
groß ist vielleicht ja auch ganz gut
steht er da steht ja schon mal fertig
macht direkt bei dem kranich hier muss
ich komplett ordentlich halten
das muss hier bei dem gar nicht
unbedingt alles kommt perfekt gefaltet
werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist mein team eine figur kann ich
nicht ich kann ja ist nämlich viel er
sich gemerkt hat tatsächlich war es
schon nicht ganz einfach sind schon
viele falsche bewegungen sondern sich
dann merken muss
[Musik]
also was markt gebracht das könnte sich
dafür entscheiden ich fange ich von
nokian ja ja das billigste was ich haben
will was ich habe ist marienkäfer das
ist ein dickes ding da sind letztes ding
lassen
da sind wenn jede szene dann fange ich
an mit einer überraschung an
ok eine eigenkreation ich hoffe die gibt
es extra punkte ein frosch einer der
schon mal sehr gut springen
ich bin jetzt nicht so gut ja doch aber
das ist ein bisschen der beiden
zumindest nicht wenn ich dachte das ist
ja der nächsten zeit und häppchen gebaut
also niemand los das ding was ich habe
ist der schwan acht der spanier war auch
dabei erwarten ist dass der schwan oder
kranich das ist der kann ich keinen
großen unterschied ist alles okay da
manchmal die rinde man kann nicht weiter
sein heißt ja 3000 mal besser als weiter
dann lege ich mir direkt nach aus dem
hohen haus ist ob ein paar mal die euro
bezahlen ich muss ja nachziehen
gegen ma lin rund um den hund ich weiß
nicht ob der gut geworden jetzt juli
sechs dinge und das ist mein hund kennt
ihn schon ein bisschen weiter hinten
naja bei ist ein hund wir sind ist ein
hund was ist das denn pascal ja ich kann
mir nicht mal angedacht
ich denke das war vor der fehler ja ich
habe nichts mehr alles
jetzt steht sogar zu sehen achten sie
also theoretisch zwei punkte
ich habe eine blaue heule das ist
einfach zehn punkte sie ist komplett
ständig etwas das ist einfach zu heftig
ich sah dass laut viel zu einem drink
alter sagt es ja auch reis geringsten
gewesen hätte zuerst drei viermal
gewonnen stimmen
okay die kommentare wie es fand ja was
war was die band experiment leicht gibt
es auch noch eine strafe zahlen
warum finden wir wettbewerb eigentlich
so spannend ist doch eigentlich nur
dummes gehabe aber auch wenn wettbewerb
nicht nur gute seiten hat ist er es der
die menschheit bis zum mond gebracht hat
das buch nun von wendel handelt vom mond
seine vergangenheit und wie und warum
wir mit einer mondstation teil seiner
zukunft werden sollten entdeckt habe ich
das auf blinkt ist flink ist unterstützt
bald hat einem jahr diesen kanal und die
sind so voll dass die diese sponsoring
nicht mal mehr sehen wollen bevor ich's
hoch lachte und sie machen eine sache
echt großartig sie komprimieren
wissenschafts persönlichkeitsentwicklung
und andere bücher auf eine 15 minuten
lesezeit oder höher zeit wenn er auf
entfernt von halt so wie ich und da
sogar in doppelter geschwindigkeit das
ist wiederum perfekt um in kürzester
zeit ein meer von wissen an zu sammeln
und als mensch zu wachsen in wichtigen
bereichen wie finanzen psychologie
unternehmertum und viele mehr natürlich
nicht nur auf deutsch sondern auch auf
englisch wenn ihr möchtet müsst euch
jetzt sieben tage lang komplett
kostenlos so viel lebens verändern es
wissen ein bisschen davor platz auf
linke.de / noch bevor ihr ein jahres abo
abschließt wenn ihr danach überzeugt
sagt adir 20 prozent rabatt auf das
jahres-abo blickes premium ganz oben
eine wegbeschreibung linke.de stommel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja